más de 740.000 millones de dólares en
programas del ejército de construcción
es una parte de la financiación que
queda ahora en el limbo tras el veto de
donald trump contra el presupuesto anual
de defensa argumentando que el
mencionado plan no incluye medidas
cruciales para la seguridad nacional
trump volvió a destruir un acuerdo
alcanzado de manera bipartidista en el
congreso varias horas antes el
presidente se negó a firmar el paquete
de ayuda contra el qb 19 también
aprobado por demócratas y republicanos
tras meses de negociaciones fue a través
de este vídeo que según la agencia pese
gravoso del conocimiento de buena parte
de su círculo cercano el mismo
secretario del tesoro se vio sorprendido
por la petición de trump de subir de 600
a 2.000 dólares la ayuda para cada
ciudadano y también es sorpresa desde la
administración venidera
e incluso el portavoz del senado dijo
que no recibieron comentarios del
presidente sé que los demócratas
ciertamente querían más ayuda de los 600
dólares la gente está sufriendo y
necesitamos llevarles asistencia de
manera inmediata desde el partido
demócrata ya algunos senadores han
expresado la voluntad de pasar por
encima de los vetos del presidente
cuando vuelvan a reunirse la próxima
semana
trump por su parte viajó a florida para
unas vacaciones de más de una semana